bonjour à tous mais que veut dire ce
titre acquis a fait cette vie n'est
digne des pires dit niet que j'ai pu
faire en 2016 l'abbé launay fogli
peut-elle se soigner à l'aide de
l'acupuncture vous aurez toutes les
réponses et même plus dans cette vidéo
en vrai cette vidéo est très importante
genre vraiment regarder la en entier
bien jusqu'au bout car il se peut que
vous appreniez des petites choses que
vous ne saviez pas c'est la définition
du mot apprendre lumière il ya quelques
jours nous avons passé le million
d'abonnés sur cette chaîne c'est
incroyable et je vous remercie
sincèrement le 16 janvier sortira la
vidéo spéciale du million parce que là
vous m'avez pris un petit peu de cours
aujourd'hui on va parler de ce qui est
réellement le mentalisme et de sa
définition en 2016 j'avais fait une
vidéo sur le sujet en 2017 une autre
j'en parle dans chacun de mes spectacles
dans chacun de mes livres mais il ya un
mais et paf et de vidéos sur le sujet en
2018 bon ben c'est de ma faute aussi
et avec l'arrivée massive des nouveaux
abonnés bienvenue les nouveaux je lis
souvent des choses dans les commentaires
qui vont de c'est pas du mentalisme il a
fait comme sherlock holmes à à espèces
d'escrocs c'est des complices et foule
fake et je vous dis ben non ils n'ont
pas compris ce que c'est le mentalisme
alors j'en suis arrivé à la conclusion
suivante les vidéos que j'ai fait sur la
définition du mentalisme sont trop
anciennes les nouveaux abonnés ne l'ont
pas vu il est temps d'en faire une autre
en rajoutant quelques petites
révélations croustillantes
je vous ai dit de tout bien regarder en
entier et je vous dirai aussi ce qui va
se passer cette année sur cette chaîne
et bonne année tout le monde on se fait
ça en cinq étapes
d'où vient le mot mentalist quelle est
sa définition
et bien ça c'est mon mois de la vidéo du
19 septembre 2007 qui va vous le dire
la paternité du mot mentalisme vient
d'un philosophe anglais de la fin du 19e
siècle qu'il avait utilisé pour
l'opposer complètement matérialisme
celle inverse
mais en même temps on trouve le mot
mentalisme dans le domaine du spectacle
des arts du spectacle jean eugène robert
houdin avait écrit dans un livre comment
on devient sorcier plein d'expérience
sur la prestidigitation de l'esprit on
pourrait aussi appeler ça la magie
mentale
vous comprenez donc surtout qu'il n'ya
pas de définition légale dans le monde
concernant ce mot mais que dit wikipedia
à ce sujet le mentalisme et dernière du
spectacle qui consiste à présenter des
performances sur les thèmes de l'étrange
les facultés mentales
les mentalistes utilise différentes
techniques entre autres la psychologie
déduction avec la lecture à froid
intuition équivoque la suggestion
lowe's le développement de la mémoire
des mots techniques calcul rapide
l'illusion prestidigitation manipulation
magie mentale
au final il ya autant de définitions
qu'il ya de mentalist et je sais que la
mienne est proche de celle de mes
contemporains berenson viktor vincent
luc langevin et bien d'autres et que
nous avons la même approche sur le sujet
est sur le terrain et là vous vous dites
mais alors c'est que du spectacle c'est
pas si simple
voici le premier chapitre de mes deux
livres oui je mets des leaders pour lire
une juge pas je me suis définit ainsi je
me suis auto proclamé mentalist personne
ne m'a adoubé c'est donc mon cas est
celui de tous les mentalistes nous nous
sommes tous autoproclamé ainsi il est
donc important lorsque vous lisez engagé
apprenez regarder un mentaliste que vous
connaissiez ce qu'il met derrière ce mot
pour ma part le mentalisme vise à
exploiter les possibilités in et que
nous offre notre mental dans le but
d'être plus performant plus autonome et
de vivre mieux mais aussi dans le but de
divertir de bluffer d'interpeller les
outils que je vais utiliser bien ainsi
du monde de la psychologie de la
déduction de l'affluence de la
prestidigitation de la mnémotechnique et
de la visualisation au final tout ce que
je peux faire en public ou en vidéo et
rationnelle à 100% est entièrement
explicable je me défends de posséder un
quelconque pouvoir ou dont il expliqué
tout le monde peut être amené à
reproduire ce que je fait moyennement
une somme de travail apprentissage
recherche curiosité et entraînement dont
il est bien clair que je n'ai aucun nom
aucun pouvoir spécial que tout ce que je
fais est explicable
comme je peux d'ailleurs le dire sur
scène c'est beaucoup plus clair le
mentalisme
tout
le messie c'est plus clair dans ce que
ça donnait pas je suis pas médium je
pars en voyant j'ai pas de super
pouvoirs pour entrer dans la tête des
gens ici j'adorerais en fait je vis des
techniques rationnelle je peux vous
jurer que 100% de mon spectacle
s'explique et manière rationnelle du
début à la fin
deuxième étape le mentalisme pour
bluffer puisque ça mélange tout alors à
quoi ça sert et comment avec un public
c'est pour le divertir et rendent la
chose fun et là je vais utiliser la
phrase que ceux qui viennent me voir en
conférence connaissent lorsque je fais
un tour sur scène ou un public
alors tous les coups sont permis le but
c'est le bluff et le divertissement avec
comme limite évidemment de ne jamais
utiliser de complices mais bon ça entre
tous mes spectacles depuis 2011 m et 600
vidéos sur youtube ça en aurait fait des
complices et puis j'ai pas le budget
pour
plus sérieusement ça veut dire que quand
je fais du mentalisme pour vous bluffer
ce n'est pas toujours celui que je dis
et ce n'est pas non plus toujours celui
que vous interprétez et ça c'est génial
mais bon vous le savez forcément du tout
les vidéos que j'ai fait sur ma chaîne
pour vous apprendre à vous à faire des
numéros pour bluffer quelqu'un en
mélangeant ça comme celui ci où l'effet
est une espèce de divination très
géométrique je pense que c'est plein de
petits picots sur l'extérieur et je
pense que le symbole que tu as choisie
c'est celui ci oui c'est bon oui
x est bon donc la personne a choisi un
symbole elle ne l'oubliera pas imaginons
que c'est celui ci vous avez vu dans
quelles zones c'était donc dans votre
tête vous savez que c'est dans le 1 2 3
4 c'est tout ce que vous avez à retenir
c'est dans le 1 2 3 4
c'est lui c'est pareil dans mes livres
ou sur les cinquante chapitres il ya
toujours une dizaine de chapitres avec
des tours comme ça
il y a des dizaines et des dizaines de
vidéos sur cette chaîne qui vous
permette vous aussi de bluffer les gens
avec du mentalisme si vous en avez envie
il y à aussi l'illusionnisme pur pour
assurer le mentalisme mais ça on en
reparlera l'étape 4 3e étape
le mentalisme pour apprendre c'est la
partie la plus personnelle du mentalisme
essayer de voir les choses différemment
et d'apprendre
ici pas besoin de résultat proche de
100% comme lorsqu'on fait le show
puisque c'est pour sa propre vie ça
englobe la détection de mensonge la
lecture du non verbal est ce que l'on
peut en faire la lecture des
micro-expressions comment mieux se
concentrer et c'est aussi le sujet d'un
gros nombre de mes vidéos et on retrouve
ça dans mes livres ou les quelques
conférences que je fais d'ailleurs vous
m'avez souvent demandée en commentaires
montrent la grande
alors j'ai fait des formations en
hypnothérapie formation pnl même s'il ya
du tri à faire là dedans formation à
signer ago logis même si un énorme tri à
faire là dedans formation en micro
expressions et j'en passe et quasi
quotidiennement
je complète ça avec mes lectures soit
pour apprendre sur le sujet soit pour
mme actualisé toujours sur le sujet en
fait au final ma limite dans cette
catégorie c'est la science dure quand je
vous explique quelque chose mais
attention je n'ai rien inventé
je ne suis qu'un passeur de savoir
passionnant et je suis moi même
passionné d'ailleurs avant 2011 quand je
suis passé sur scène en théâtre je
vivais entre autres des formations que
je donnais sur le sujet dans le milieu
professionnel
après le but c'est de rendre ça
accessible en astuces pratiques pour la
vraie vie comme dans cette vidéo
premier point c'est bien sûr la
classique poignée de main cancer la main
à quelqu'un surtout pour la première
fois ça veut toujours dire quelque chose
bien sûr la liste de ce qu'on peut
mettre dans cette catégorie du
mentalisme n'est pas exhaustive
elle dépend simplement de vous de vos
envies de vos besoins
en gros de votre définition 4e étape le
mélange des genres
c'est pour ça que je refais une vidéo
définition sur le sujet que j'en parle à
chacun de mes spectacles et que j'y
consacre un chapitre dans chacun de mes
livres il ya parfois une ambiguïté entre
le mentalisme pour apprendre et celui
pour bluffer c'est normal c'est du
divertissement
si vous compreniez toujours tout à
chaque fois ce serait aussi plat qu'un
magicien qui vous fait un tour de cartes
tout en nous expliquant en même temps
c'est pourquoi quand vous voyez un
mentaliste sur scène que ce soit moi ou
les collègues précédemment 6
et alors ils vont mélanger
l'illusionnisme la psychologie la
déduction l'influencent la mémoire dans
le but de vous divertir c'est un savoir
qui se transmet au travers des livres
un petit peu comme dans ma bibliothèque
que vous voyez souvent derrière moi en
vidéo j'avais d'ailleurs fait une
conférence sur ce sujet en 2016 que vous
pouvez retrouver sur internet mais
parfois l'illusionnisme sert de plan b
comme dans cette vidéo sur une carte
choisir un autre qui n'est pas trafiqué
non regardez vous pouvez l'acheter par
tous les bas ici quelques voiliers dans
tous les films
ok donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse alors à tours de cartes
vous avez vu ma gêne à ce moment là mais
ça c'est parce que j'ai pas anticipé
j'utilise un jeu bicycle ce qui me
permet de sécuriser en cas de raté ce
qui arrive à tous les mentalistes vous
m'avez déjà vue faire quelques feuilles
déjà sur cette chaîne à ce moment précis
je dois à la fois expliquer des choses
vraies scientifiquement le mentalisme
pour apprendre et à la fois les bluffer
le mentalisme pour divertir si jamais je
me rate ça me permet d'enchaîner car
avoir un jeu que je connais me permet de
sécuriser
alors ce sera moins propre ce sera moins
précis ce sera moins pur mais il y aura
quand même un résultat ce qui est
important quand on n'a pas l'occasion
d'enchaîner avec un autre numéro pour se
rattraper
comme c'est le cas sur les plateaux télé
ou sur les plateaux d'artistes
d'ailleurs dans cette même émission
quelques secondes avant je dis ça mais
dans ma définition du mentalisme a du
coup c'est un mélange de mémoire de de
connaissances sur le langage non verbal
ou la psychologie et de connaissances
scientifiques parce que pendant quelque
chose qui se dit aussi qu'ils sont aussi
de l'ordre du fantasme de suggestions
parfois d'illusionnisme quand on veut
bluffé on peut associer les deux
pourquoi pas ça après je vous cache pas
que parfois je tente des coups avec peu
ou pas de sécurité pour bluffer tout le
monde c'est à dire vous les spectateurs
les magiciens les collègues mentalisme
tout le monde et que là je suis en sueur
un petit peu comme le toit sur ces 8
alors voilà il a fait plein de
mouvements que j'ai pas fait attention à
trop on va le faire voir ensemble à la
caméra qui a là bas et je fais en
pression 3 mon corps plus récemment et
plus risquées chez michel drucker le 30
décembre dernier alors que j'étais au 15
9 2 si aucun regard c'est parce que vous
avez dessiné
parce que moi aussi je suis un petit peu
stressé il y en même temps peut-être que
vous croyez sur parole et qu'on a pas
besoin de vous faire voir je propose de
24 ans retourne tous les deux
votre bonne résolution et on va voir ce
que j'ai perçu ce que vous avez fait un
deux trois d'ailleurs il faut pas faire
de raccourcis et tout mélanger prenons
l'exemple de trouver une pièce qui
cachaient dans la main de quelqu'un
alors qu'il existe des systèmes de
magicien pour retrouver automatiquement
ou et la pièce à l'aide d'un matériel
secret sans trop vous en dévoiler il
faut avoir le matériel et la pièce
spéciale mais c'est pas parce que ça
existe que le mentaliste utilise à vous
voyez la nuance
personnellement pour faire ça j'utilise
uniquement des techniques de mentalisme
d'observation et d'ailleurs je vous
invite si un jour vous me croisez où que
ce soit à prendre l'une de vos pièces et
à me mettre au défi de trouver dans
quelles mains vous la mettez je le ferai
que ce soit dans la rue dans un train
dans un magasin même à la piscine je le
ferai 5e étape
lire plus de mentalisme sur la chaîne je
taquine mais c'est pour vous faire et qu
est ce que je peux lire parfois dans les
commentaires il ya le même ratio de
mentalisme sur cette chaîne en 2018
qu'en 2017 qu'en 2016 cette chaîne elle
traite de deux choses du mentalisme et
de mes patients sur tout ce qui touche
le mental du coup la chaîne est découpé
en quatre catégories
le mentalisme comme le mentalisme dans
la rue en décembre
le mental game comme les casse-têtes
d'ailleurs j'en faisais 4 par mois je
pense que je vais réduire à deux par
mois cette année pour en trouver des
plus sympas le mental fun comme la
chasse aux trésors la red box en
décembre le mental tips ça ce sont les
astuces comme la vidéo sur le code
vigenère de décembre donc cette année je
continue à explorer ces quatre
catégories en essayant d'équilibrer
parfois un petit peu mieux tout ça il y
aura toujours une vidéo de mercredi
matin à 6h et au minimum une deuxième le
samedi matin ou le vendredi soir si vous
suivez depuis un petit moment vous savez
aussi qu'il ya une série qui va sortir
cette année fin d'année j'espère une
sorte de série qui fait marcher votre
mental dont vous avez encore voir passer
quelques partenariats pour financer tout
ça de votre côté vous pouvez soutenir
mon travail est parfois les grosses
productions en désactivant adblock quand
vous regardez mes vidéos ou en
rejoignant la communauté de la chaîne
via le bouton rejoindre à quelques
avantages
il ya un lien dans la description vous
souhaite une très belle année 2010 9
n'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce en
l'air abonnez-vous à la chaîne si ce
n'est pas encore fait réalisez vous ne
doutez pas n'attendez pas des parfaits
on ne l'est jamais essayé de faire ce
que vous repoussez depuis très longtemps
car un peu toujours mieux que 0 à très
bientôt
ciao